Loops are one essential part of
programming and in Python we have two
kinds of Loops while loops and for Loops
while Loops are defined using the while
keyword and they repeat their block
until the condition is evaluated as
false so here's a while loop with a
counter so you you start the counter at
zero and then while count is less than
10 we're going to print this count
equals count plus one so it's going to
increment the counter every time until
we get to the end and other type is the
for Loop so using four Loops we can tell
python to execute a block for a
predetermined amount of times up front
and without the need of a separate
variable and conditional to check its
value or items here and then four item
and items for each item in the list
we're going to print the item pretty
straightforward